ANNOUNCER: Open content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu .
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
All right.
That said, let's continue, and
if you remember last time, we
ended up looking at this thing
I called square roots bi.
This was using something called
a bisection method,
which is related to something
called binary search, which
we'll see lots more of later,
to find square roots.
And the basic idea was that we
had some sort of a line, and
we knew the answer was somewhere
between this point
and this point.
The line is totally ordered.
And what that means, is that
anything here is smaller than
anything to its right.
So the integers are totally
ordered, the reals are totally
ordered, lots of
things are, the
rationals are totally ordered.
And that idea was, we make a
guess in the middle, we test
it so this is kind of a guess
and check, and if the answer
was too big, then we knew
that we should be
looking over here.
If it was too small, we knew
we should be looking over
here, and then we
would repeat.
So this is very similar, this
is a kind of recursive
thinking we talked about
earlier, where we take our
problem and we make it smaller,
we solve a smaller
problem, et cetera.
All right.
So now, we've got it, I've
got the code up for you.
I want you to notice the
specifications to start.
We're assuming that x is greater
than or equal to 0,
and epsilon is strictly greater
than 0, and we're
going to return some value y
such that y squared is within
epsilon of x.
I'd last time talked about the
two assert statements.
In some sense, strictly speaking
they shouldn't be
necessary, because the fact that
my specification starts
with an assumption, says, hey
you, who might call square
root, make sure that the things
you call me with obey
the assumption.
On the other hand, as I said,
never trust a programmer to do
the right thing, so we're
going to check it.
And just in case the assumptions
are not true,
we're just going to stop
dead in our tracks.
All right.
Then we're going to set low to--
low and high, and we're
going to perform exactly the
process I talked about.
And along the way, I'm keeping
track of how many iterations,
at the end I'll print how many
iterations I took, before I
return the final guess.
All right, let's test it.
So one of the things I want you
to observe here, is that
instead of sitting there and
typing away a bunch of test
cases, I took the trouble to
write a function, called test
bi in this case.
All right, so what that's doing,
is it's taking the
things I would normally type,
and putting them in a
function, which I
can then call.
Why is that better
than typing them?
Why was it worth creating
a function to do this?
Pardon?
STUDENT:: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: Then I
can I can use it again and
again and again.
Exactly.
By putting it in a function, if
I find a bug and I change
my program, I can just run
the function again.
The beauty of this is, it keeps
me from getting lazy,
and not only testing my program
and the thing that
found the bug, but in all the
things that used to work.
We'll talk more about this
later, but it often happens
that when you change your
program to solve one problem,
you break it, and things that
used to work don't work.
And so what you want to do, and
again we'll come back to
this later in the term,
is something
called regression testing.
This has nothing to do with
linear regression.
And that's basically trying to
make sure our program has not
regressed, as to say,
gone backwards
in how well it works.
And so we always test
it on everything.
All right?
So I've created this function,
let's give it a shot and see
what happens.
We'll run test bi.
Whoops!
All right, well let's
look at our answers.
I first tested it on the square
root of 4, and in one
iteration it found 2.
I like that answer.
I then tested it on the square
root of 9, and as I mentioned
last time, I didn't find 3.
I was not crushed.
You know, I was not really
disappointed, it found
something close enough
to 3 that I'm happy.
All right.
I tried it on 2, I surely didn't
expect a precise and
exact answer to that, but I
got something, and if you
square this, you'll find
the answer kept pretty
darn close to 2.
I then tried it on
0.25 One quarter.
And what happened was
not what I wanted.
As you'll see, it crashed.
It didn't really crash, it found
an assert statement.
So if you look at the bottom
of the function, you'll see
that, in fact, I checked
for that.
I assert the counter is less
than or equal to 0.
I'm checking that I didn't leave
my program because I
didn't find an answer.
Well, this is a good thing, it's
better than my program
running forever, but it's a bad
thing because I don't have
it the square root of 0.25.
What went wrong here?
Well, let's think about
it for a second.
You look like-- someone
looks like they're
dying to give an answer.
No, you just scratching
your head?
All right.
Remember, I said when we do
a bisection method, we're
assuming the answer lies
somewhere between the lower
bound and the upper bound.
Well, what is the square
root of a quarter?
It is a half.
Well, what-- where did
I tell my program
to look for an answer?
Between 0 and x.
So the problem was, the answer
was over here somewhere, and
so I'm never going to find it
cleverly searching in this
region, right?
So the basic idea was fine, but
I failed to satisfy the
initial condition that the
answer had to be between the
lower bound and the
upper bound.
Right?
And why did I do that?
Because I forgot what happens
when you look at fractions.
So what should I do?
Actually I lied, by the way,
when I said the answer was
over there.
Where was the answer?
Somebody?
It was over here.
Because the square root of a
quarter is not smaller than a
quarter, it's bigger
than a quarter.
Right?
A half is strictly greater
than a quarter.
So it wasn't on the region.
So how-- what's the fix?
Should be a pretty simple fix,
in fact we should be able to
do it on the fly, here.
What should I change?
Do I need to change
the lower bound?
Is the square root ever going
to be less than 0?
Doesn't need to be, so, what
should I do about the upper
bound here?
Oh, I could cheat and make, OK,
the upper bound a half,
but that wouldn't
be very honest.
What would be a good
thing to do here?
Pardon?
I could square x, but maybe
I should just do something
pretty simple here.
Suppose-- whoops.
Suppose I make it the
max of x and 1.
Then if I'm looking for the
square root of something less
than 1, I know it will be
in my region, right?
All right, let's save
this, and run it
and see what happens.
Sure enough, it worked and, did
we get-- we got the right
answer, 0.5 All right?
And by the way, I checked
all of my previous ones,
and they work too.
All right.
Any questions about
bisection search?
One of the things I want you to
notice here is the number
iterations is certainly
not constant.
Yeah, when I will looked at 4,
it was a nice number like 1, 9
looked like it took me 18, 2
took me 14, if we try some big
numbers it might take
even longer.
These numbers are small, but
sometimes when we look at
really harder problems, we got
ourselves in a position where
we do care about the number of
iterations, and we care about
something called the speed
of convergence.
Bisection methods were known to
the ancient Greeks, and it
is believed by many, even
to the Babylonians.
And as I mentioned last time,
this was the state of the art
until the 17th century.
At which point, things
got better.
So, let's think about it, and
let's think about what we're
actually doing when
we solve this.
When we look for something like
the square root of x,
what we're really doing,
is solving an equation.
We're looking at the equation
f of guess equals the guess
squared minus x.
Right, that's what that is equal
to, and we're trying to
solve the equation that
f of guess equals 0.
Looking for the root
of this equation.
So if we looked at it
pictorially, what we've got
here is, we're looking at f of
x, I've plotted it here, and
we're asking where it
crosses the x axis.
Sorry for the overloading
of the word x.
And I'm looking here at 16.
Square root of 16, and my plot
basically shows it crosses at
4 and-- well, I think
that's minus 4.
The perspective is tricky--
and so we're
trying to find the roots.
Now Isaac Newton and/or Joseph
Raphson figured out how to do
this kind of thing for all
differentiable functions.
Don't worry about
what that means.
The basic idea is, you take a
guess, and you -- whoops --
and you find the tangent
of that guess.
So let's say I guessed 3.
I look for the tangent
of the curve at 3.
All right, so I've got the
tangent, and then my next
guess is going to be where the
tangent crosses the x axis.
So instead of dividing it in
half, I'm using a different
method to find the next guess.
The utility of this relies upon
the observation that,
most of the time-- and I want to
emphasize this, most of the
time, that implies not all of
the time-- the tangent line is
a good approximation
to the curve for
values near the solution.
And therefore, the x intercept
of the tangent will be closer
to the right answer than
the current guess.
Is that always true,
by the way?
Show me a place where that's
not true, where the tangent
line will be really bad.
Yeah.
Suppose I choose it right
down there, I guess 0.
Well, the tangent there will not
even have an x intercept.
So I'm really going to
be dead in the water.
This is the sort of thing that
people who do numerical
programming worry about
all the time.
And there are a lot of a little
tricks they use to deal
with that, they'll perturb
it a little
bit, things like that.
You should not, at
this point, be
worrying about those things.
This method, interestingly
enough, is actually the method
used in most hand calculators.
So if you've got a calculator
that has a square root button,
it's actually in the calculator
running Newton's method.
Now I know you thought it was
going to do that thing you
learned in high school for
finding square roots, which I
never could quite understand,
but no.
It uses Newton's method
to do it.
So how do we find the intercept
of the tangent, the
x intercept?
Well this is where derivatives
come in.
What we know is that the slope
of the tangent is given by the
first derivative of the
function f at the
point of the guess.
So the slope of the guess
is the first derivative.
Right.
Which dy over dx.
Change in y divided
by change in x.
So we can use some algebra,
which I won't go through here,
and what we would find is that
for square root, the
derivative, written f prime of
the i'th guess is equal to two
times the i'th guess.
Well, should have left myself
a little more room, sorry
about that.
All right?
You could work this out.
Right?
The derivative of the
square root is not
a complicated thing.
Therefore, and here's the key
thing we need to keep in mind,
we'll know that we can choose
guess i plus 1 to be equal to
the old guess, guess i, minus
whatever the value is of the
new guess-- of the old rather,
the old guess-- divided by
twice the old guess.
All right, again this is
straightforward kind of
algebraic manipulations
to get here.
So let's look at an example.
Suppose we start looking for
the square root of 16
with the guess 3.
What's the value of the
function f of 3?
Well, it's going to be, we
looked at our function there,
guess squared, 3 times 3 is 9 I
think, minus 16, that's what
x is in this case, which
equals minus 7.
That being the case, what's
my next guess?
Well I start with my old guess,
3, minus f of my old
guess, which is minus 7, divided
by twice my old guess,
which is 6, minus the minus,
and I get as my new guess
4.1666 or thereabouts.
So you can see I've missed,
but I am closer.
And then I would reiterate this
process using that as
guess i, and do it again.
One way to think about this
intuitively, if the derivative
is very large, the function
is changing quickly, and
therefore we want to
take small steps.
All right.
If the derivative is small, it's
not changing, maybe want
to take a larger step,
but let's not worry
about that, all right?
Does this method work
all the time?
Well, we already saw no, if my
initial guess is zero, I don't
get anywhere.
In fact, my program crashes
because I end up trying to
divide by zero, a really
bad thing.
Hint: if you implement Newton's
method, do not make
your first guess zero.
All right, so let's look
at the code for that.
All right so-- yeah, how do I
get to the code for that?
That's interesting.
All right.
So we have that square
root NR.
NR for Newton Raphson.
First thing I want you to
observe is its specification
is identical to the
specification
of square root bi.
What that's telling me is that
if you're a user of this, you
don't care how it's
implemented, you
care what it does.
And therefore, it's fine that
the specifications are
identical, in fact it's a good
thing, so that means if
someday Professor Grimson
invents something that's
better than Newton Raphson, we
can all re-implement our
square root functions and none
of the programs that use it
will have to change,
as long as the
specification is the same.
All right, so, not much
to see about this.
As I said, the specifications is
the same, same assertions,
and the-- it's basically the
same program as the one we
were just looking at, but I'm
starting with a different
guess, in this case x over 2,
well I'm going to, couple of
different guesses we can start
with, we can experiment with
different guesses and see
whether we get the same
answer, and in fact, if we did,
we would see we didn't
get this, we got different
answers, but correct answers.
Actually now, we'll just
comment that out.
I'm going to compute the
difference, just as I did on
the board, and off we'll go.
All right.
Now, let's try and compare
these things.
And what we're going to look at
is another procedure, you
have the code for these things
on your handout so we won't
worry, don't need to show you
the code, but let's look at
how we're going to test it.
I'm doing a little trick by the
way, I'm using raw input
in my function here, as a just
a way to stop the display.
This way I can torture
you between tests
by asking you questions.
Making it stop.
All right, so, we'll
try some things.
We'll see what it does.
Starting with that, well, let's
look at some of the
things it will do.
Yeah, I'll save it..
It's a little bit annoying, but
it makes the font bigger.
All right, so we've tested it,
and we haven't tested it yet,
we have tested it but, we
haven't seen it, well, you
know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to tort--
I'm going to make the font
smaller so we can see more.
Sorry about this.
Those of you in the back, feel
free to move forward.
All right.
So we've got it, now
let's test it.
So we're going to do
here, we're going
to run compare methods.
Well we're seeing this famous
computers are no damn good.
All right.
So we're going to try it on 2,
and at least we'll notice for
2, that the bisection method
took eight iterations, the
Newton Raphson only took three,
so it was more efficient.
They came up with slightly
different answers, but both
answers are within .01 which
is what I gave it here for
epsilon, so we're OK.
So even though they have
different answers, they both
satisfy the same specification,
so we have no problem.
All right?
Try it again, just for fun.
I gave it here a different
epsilon, and you'll note, we
get different answers.
Again, that's OK.
Notice here, when I asked for
a more precise answer,
bisection took a lot more
iterations, but Newton Raphson
took only one extra iteration to
get that extra precision in
the answer.
So we're sort of getting the
notion that Newton Raphson
maybe is considerably better on
harder problems. Which, by
the way, it is.
We'll make it an even harder
problem, by making it looking
an even smaller epsilon, and
again, what you'll see is,
Newton Raphson just crept up by
one, didn't take it long,
and got the better answer,
where bisection
gets worse and worse.
So as you can see, as we
escalate the problem
difficulty, the difference
between the good method and
the not quite as good
method gets bigger
and bigger and bigger.
That's an important observation,
and as we get to
the part of the course, we
talk about computational
complexity, you'll see that what
we really care about is
not how efficient the program
is on easy problems, but how
efficient it is on hard
problems. All right.
Look at another example.
All right, here I gave it
a big number, 123456789.
And again, I don't want to
bore you, but you can see
what's going on here
with this trend.
So here's an interesting
question.
You may notice that it's always
printing out the same
number of digits.
Why should this be?
If you look at it here,
what's going on?
Something very peculiar
is happening here.
We're looking at it, and we're
getting some funny answers.
This gets back to what I talked
about before, about
some of the precision of
floating point numbers.
And the thing I'm trying to
drive home to you here is
perhaps the most important
lesson we'll
talk about all semester.
Which is, answers
can be wrong.
People tend to think, because
the computer says it's so, it
must be so.
That the computer is--
speaks for God.
And therefore it's infallible.
Maybe it speaks for the Pope.
It speaks for something
that's infallible.
But in fact, it is not.
And so, something I find myself
repeating over and over
again to myself, to my graduate
students, is, when
you get an answer from the
computer, always ask yourself,
why do I believe it?
Do I think it's the
right answer?
Because it isn't necessarily.
So if we look at what we've got
here, we've got something
rather peculiar, right?
What's peculiar about what
this computer is now
printing for us?
Why should I be really
suspicious about what I see in
the screen here?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: Well, not
only is it different, it's
really different, right?
If it were just a little bit
different, I could say, all
right, I have a different
approximation.
But when it's this different,
something is wrong.
Right?
We'll, later in the term when
we get to more detailed
numerical things, look
at what's wrong.
You can run into issues of
things like overflow,
underflow, with floating point
numbers, and when you see a
whole bunches of ones, it's
particularly a good time to be
suspicious.
Anyway the only point I'm making
here is, paranoia is a
healthy human trait.
All right.
We can look at some other things
which will work better.
And we'll now move on.
OK.
So we've looked at how to
solve square root we've,
looked at two problems, I've
tried to instill in you this
sense of paranoia which is so
valuable, and now we're going
to pull back and return to
something much simpler than
numbers, and that's Python.
All right?
Numbers are hard.
That's why we teach whole
semesters worth of courses in
number theory.
Python it's easy, which is why
we do it in about four weeks.
All right.
I want to return to some
non-scalar types.
So we've been looking, the last
couple of lectures, at
floating point numbers
and integers.
We've looked so far really
at two non-scalar types.
And those were tuples written
with parentheses, and strings.
The key thing about
both of them is
that they were immutable.
And I responded to at least one
email about this issue,
someone quite correctly said
tuple are immutable, how can I
change one?
My answer is, you can't change
one, but you can create a new
one that is almost like the
old one but different in a
little bit.
Well now we're going to talk
about some mutable types.
Things you can change.
And we're going to start with
one that you, many of you,
have already bumped
into, perhaps by
accident, which are lists.
Lists differ from strings in two
ways; one way is that it's
mutable, the other way is that
the values need not be
characters.
They can be numbers, they can
be characters, they can be
strings, they can even
be other lists.
So let's look at some
examples here.
What we'll do, is we'll work
on two boards at once.
So I could write a statement
like, techs, a variable, is
equal to the list, written with
the square brace, not a
parenthesis, MIT, Cal
Tech, closed brace.
What that basically does, is it
takes the variable techs,
and it now makes it point to a
list with two items in it.
One is the string MIT and one
is the string Cal Tech.
So let's look at it.
And we'll now run another little
test program, show
lists, and I printed it,
and it prints the
list MIT, Cal Tech.
Now suppose I introduce a new
variable, we'll call it ivys,
and we say that is equal to the
list Harvard, Yale, Brown.
Three of the ivy league
colleges.
What that does is, I have a new
variable, ivys, and it's
now pointing to another, what we
call object, in Python and
Java, and many other languages,
think of these
things that are sitting
there in memory
somewhere as objects.
And I won't write it all out,
I'll just write it's got
Harvard as one in it, and
then it's got Yale, and
then it's got Brown.
And I can now print ivys.
And it sure enough prints what
we expected it to print.
Now, let's say I have univs, for
universities, equals the
empty list. That would create
something over here called
univs, another variable, and it
will point to the list, an
object that contains
nothing in it.
This is not the same as none.
It's it does have a value, it
just happens to be the list
that has nothing in it.
And the next thing I'm
going to write is
univs dot append tex.
What is this going to do?
It's going to take this list and
add to it something else.
Let's look at the code.
I'm going to print it, and
let's see what it prints.
It's kind of interesting.
Whoops.
Why did it do that?
That's not what I expected.
It's going to print that.
The reason it printed that is
I accidentally had my finger
on the control key, which said
print the last thing you had.
Why does it start with square
braced square brace?
I take it-- yes, go ahead.
STUDENT: So you're adding
a list to a list?
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: So I'm
adding a list to a list. What
have I-- what I've appended to
the empty list is not the
elements MIT and Cal Tech
but the list that
contains those elements.
So I've appended this
whole object.
Since that object is itself
a list, what I get
is a list of lists.
Now I should mention this
notation here append is what
is in Python called a method.
Now we'll hear lots more about
methods when we get to classes
and inheritance, but really, a
method is just a fancy word
for a function with
different syntax.
Think of this as a function that
takes two arguments, the
first of which is univs and the
second of which is techs.
And this is just a different
syntax for writing that
function call.
Later in the term, we'll see
why we have this syntax and
why it wasn't just a totally
arbitrary brain-dead decision
by the designers of Python,
and many languages before
Python, but in fact is a
pretty sensible thing.
But for now, think of this as
just another way to write a
function call.
All right, people
with me so far?
Now let's say we wanted as the
next thing we'll do, is we're
going to append the ivys
to univ. Stick
another list on it.
All right.
So we'll do that, and now we get
MIT, Cal Tech, followed by
that list followed by the list
Harvard, Yale, Brown.
So now we have a list containing
two lists.
What are we going to try next?
Well just to see what we know
what we're doing, let's look
at this code here.
I've written a little for
loop, which is going to
iterate over all of the elements
in the list. So
remember, before we wrote things
like for i in range 10,
which iterated over a list or
tuple of numbers, here you can
iterate over any list, and so
we're going to just going to
take the list called univs
and iterate over it.
So the first thing we'll do is,
we'll print the element,
in this case it will
be a list, right?
Because it's a list with
two lists in it.
Then the next thing in the loop,
we're going to enter a
nested loop, and say for every
college in the list e, we're
going to print the name
of the college.
So now if we look what we get--
do you not want to try
and execute that?-- it'll
first print the list
containing MIT and Cal Tech,
and then separately the
strings MIT and Cal Tech, and
then the list containing
Harvard, Yale, and Brown, and
then the strings Harvard,
Yale, and Brown.
So we're beginning to see this
is a pretty powerful notion,
these lists, and that
we can do a lot of
interesting things with them.
Suppose I don't want all of this
structure, and I want to
do what's called flattening the
list. Well I can do that
by, instead of using the
method append, use the
concatenation operator.
So I can concatenate techs
plus ivys and assign that
result to univs, and then when
I print it you'll notice I
just get a list of
five strings.
So plus and append do very
different things.
Append sticks the list on the
end of the list, append
flattens it, one level
of course.
If I had lists of lists of
lists, then it would only take
out the first level of it.
OK, very quiet here.
Any questions about
any of this?
All right.
Because we're about to get
to the hard part Sigh.
All right.
Let's look at the-- well,
suppose I want to, quite
understandably, eliminate
Harvard.
All right, I then get
down here, where I'm
going to remove it.
So this is again another method,
this is remove, takes
two arguments, the first
is ivys, the second
is the string Harvard.
It's going to search through the
list until the first time
it finds Harvard and then it's
going to yank it away.
So what happened here?
Did I jump to the wrong place?
STUDENT: You hit two returns.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
I hit two returns.
Pardon?
STUDENT: You hit two returns.
One was at
STUDENT: Pardo
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
This one.
STUDENT: No, up one.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: Up one.
STUDENT: Right.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: But
why is Harvard there?
STUDENT: I'm sorry, I didn't
write it down.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: Let's
look at it again.
All right, it's time to
interrupt the world, and we'll
just type into the shell.
Let's see what we get here.
All right, so let's just see
what we got, we'll print
univs. Nope, not defined.
All right, well let's do a list
equals, and we'll put
some interesting things in it,
we'll put a number in it,
because we can put a number,
we'll put MIT in it, because
we can put strings, we'll put
another number in it, 3.3,
because we can put floating
points, we can put all sorts
of things in this list. We can
put a list in the list again,
as we've seen before.
So let's put the list containing
the string a, and
I'll print out, so now we see
something pretty interesting
about a list, that we can mix up
all sorts of things in it,
and that's OK.
You'll notice I have the string
with the number 1, a
string with MIT, and then it
just a plain old number, not a
string, again it didn't quite
give me 3.3 for reasons we've
talked before, and now
it in the list a.
So, suppose I want to
remove something.
What should we try and remove
from this list?
Anybody want to vote?
Pardon?
All right, someone wants
to remove MIT.
Sad but true.
Now what do we get
if we print l?
MIT is gone.
How do I talk about the
different pieces of l?
Well I can do this. l sub 0--
whoops-- will give me the
first element of the list,
just as we could do with
strings, and I can look at l
sub minus 1 to get the last
element of the list, so I can
do all the strings, all the
things that I could
do with strings.
It's extremely powerful,
but what we
haven't seen yet is mutation.
Well, we have seen
mutation, right?
Because notice that what remove
did, it was it actually
changed the list. Didn't create
a new list. The old l
is still there, but it's
different than it used to be.
So this is very different from
what we did with slicing,
where we got a new copy
of something.
Here we took the old one
and we just changed it.
On Thursday, we'll look at why
that allows you to do lots of
things more conveniently than
you can do without mutation.